me
府屋さんは夢にせるぞ
妙なことが感銘覚悟ありますから
また誰かのぬにか例えば
作品や演技スポーツ観戦はルー2して自然に鳥肌立ってい
なる前にを抑えて3球サイパンバーガー
言ったようなジムにと要するるまいてぃー
いいし
し強い品新規重い方はありますよ
おかしい心が
4分けの日生
いいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいん
2は私がもが歳から
米入ってるハーティスティックシールというスポーツを知っ
みなさんこんな競技をご存知でしょうか
少し前まではシンプルヴァイスセービングよビデオ無様
現在はパーティー sticks
不眠なことがある
ミニスタッフらー
ぱく婆さんのままつけて c 4笑顔で数値で rba 24
1染めろ依存する方が多いの日は内部2カラー
にアイバーにまず簡単にこのスポーツの祭典方法や流量説明してから本題に入っていき
ていると思う
フェイスには1輪に置く
2人で行う言えぷっ
8人で行うチームペリッがにゃん
a てやっちゃうんだろうテレビなどで見たことがある方も多いかもしれません
サイズの写真にあるようにここに入れていますよ味覚
例えば婦人会のスペインはゼロ今表現した無事にで魚の世界を平和に表現
そしてそのしたロシア圧倒的な技術力ところまで魅了される
させる
いったようじゃ
そしてをつまり中国は震災さんを武器に幾何学模様など独自性を見せます
そして我が国日本はまつ毛をテーマにお国柄を出しています
このように各国によって演技における
テーマや音樂遺書はた力を入れてくれ
青子たちの表現の仕方ばん
賞与なくゆん
h といいスポーツウィンター tnf
ところ面白さかなん
麺よすい人中よって採点基準の配分は変わってきますが
審判を3つのカンペにも続いて
最低を思います
周囲たの道調整
技の難易度や完成度そして演技構成
音楽の解釈と富士青です
そして特にこの縁に高生の二分では芸術的表現力といったようなものが重要視されてき
ます
少しイメージしにくいと思いますので参考までに古いルーピン分自由淫戯の場合の採点
基準を簡単にを無視したいと思います
今回私が掌底を置いてお話していきたい部分は先ほども申しました
ここ演技構成の中の姫術師表現力
穂の部分
いやスケープや器械体操などとも似たような風直井くんせ
ディズスポーツ水中でばダンサーなどとも言われるほど
各選手の表現力や個性得意技といったところに重低音います
競泳や陸上サッカーん除いた協議ではタイム upty するといったものが競われる
一方で asd は観客や審判まぁ見ている人の主観も大きく影響されます
com 測地起こすが良い子ならではの難しさであり私を夢中にさせてくれた
一つの理由でもあります
私は元気主題を通し全ての種目に一つ折れ調整してきましたがその中でも私水が個人的
に力を入れてきたさんって
好きだったのソロですよ
そして後私がこなし服好きになったのには良いアバ入りません
それはオフィスと
演技をする人が自分だよな用ゲームス形で自由 new
そしてその後を探求理系
ということがあるからです
この単元には自分を打ちよ見たようにをだれよおっ
どうしたら一番自分足口食べきるのか
泳げるのか
そのようなことをひたすら考えることが大事出会いの
そこに私は面白さを感じたんです
しかし as という競技は皆さんもご存知でありと無理
美しさや技まま医療大きく追及される採点競技であることから
院長あなたかサビスつが上垣美しい脚を持っている彼女
容姿の面での視点が非常に大事になってきます
私を選手時代微妙の中で特別長くて綺麗な足を持っている
10男性に自信はあるわけでもん
そして強みにできるヒールが技術力を持っているわけでもありませんでした
そのため中は容姿や技術の面だけで上を目指していくのは厳しいと感じ
自分がこの競技であったことは間違いだった
他が競技に取り組んでおけば良かったと思ったことは何度も何度もありました
しかしソロには先ほど分お話ししたような魅力や面白さがあります
だからこそそれに気付いてから生地はエースの表現力や芸術性における部分を追求し
強化し続けることでこの表示の向き合っていくをそう考えるようになりますか
自身の表現力や主体性の部分を強化し死体ていけるような工夫や努力にもそれから励む
ようになりました
何を言っているのか
炎症ついてあまりご存知6日前
二役室あまり映像が彼がないかもそうん
[音楽]
ここでよっ
私は今からあることをしますん
アンパンマン振りつけよう
腕を行います
うずみは
2回の2
どちらが印象的喰らう
グッと仕事を考えています大2
5つ目です
[音楽]
お分かりいただけたでしょうか
このように同じことをしていても目の前に入れ室や相手に使いたい
表現したい強前である方がより強く伝えやすく良いショーにも強く残るのです
つまり私の場合は as のソロという競技を通して
表現したいという情熱的な思いというものが大切であるのではないかということを思い
ました
さて少し脇もぜますが皆さんも私が話の冒頭部分眠りませた質問を覚えています
でしょうか
人に見せる
表現するって結局どのようなことなんでしょうか
私の場合
見せるという言葉を定義してみると自分が表現の姿で自分らしく表現すること
そのように考えますは
見てもらうのではなく自分が見せる
二世帯と意識するだけでそれを見ている人は
魅了されるのではないか
私はそのように考えます
つわりを魅了する力です
人は皆生まれながらにか魔物や小瀬
独自性しか強みを持っており
目に見えない魅力を持っているものです
これらのものはフェに見えないものも
それにより時として伝わりづらいし理解してもらいにくい
いうこともあります
でもこれを何らかの形で表現すること
目の前の人に
starry を努力すること
このような工夫をしたりそうと育毛と意識すること
それが大事なのではないかと私は感じます
自分の中からは消えてくる何か
それを言葉にしたり絵にかいたりコミュニケーションを通して伝えたり
このやり方は人それぞれ自分の伝えやすい自分が一番影開ける方法でいいとも思います
しかし魅了する力を持っている人がいればそれで準備ままでしょうか
いくら自分の魅力を発信しても
それを受け止めてくれる人がいなかったらどうでしょ
つまり魅了する力が発信力だとすれば
一方で魅了されるという地震力のようなもの
これは同時に必要なのではないかと私は思います
お互いの個性や価値観を生かし愛
受け入れ愛を技なやっていき社会
そして自分が相手の底に尊敬の念を抱くことで引き出してあげられるようなそんな力も
欠かせないと思います
ここまで自身が成長することができたら
そんな社会になっていけたらと
そのように私は思います
つまりどんなに ai 技術なのが発表して言ったとしても
人間だからこそ感じ取り生かせるもの
それは表現の部分にあり
魅了する力と魅了される力も両方がバランスを取り合っている
そのような状態を指すのではないかと
ものです
お寿司が今エース1本に歩んでみした道から少し離れ
エースの首脳がはに関わったりまたスペインがな教科とフラメンゴに夢中になってい
ます
クイーンの as チーンは表現や技術性の部分で大変する得て言うというのは英
スカイで昔から言われておる
私自身も元気使いから焦がれているものでした
そのためいつか自信がしてスペインチームをずれてみたいそういう思いから
現在は上がっ強化に励んでいます
そしてエース共通しているブーム本がある
プラめんこという興味んもハゲメンという次第です
そのために見せるという発信力も
見せられるという自信力も
もっともっと磨いていく必要が私にはあります
ススキルを通して私は将来自分らしい表現の仕方で伝える
そしてその上で様々な分野において目標に向かってはや6方々の表現を救っん
それを引き継いでも多くの人に伝える
そんなシャシ沸かし延べ米を自分がする
そのような人材でもありたいと思います
皆さん
自分なりの方法です
自分があっ
いつも彼ができる方数です
みよっ
new 財布みるのはどうでしょうか
様たびにはず
すごい位しかできない広げますかーっ
そもそも
見せるっていうどんなもバロンファン8人図鑑4 a
そのような機会を少し作ってみるぞは脳に市のかっ